here at CBS News we're committed to
stopping the stigma surrounding mental
health so we can take the shame and the
blame out of discussing mental illnesses
today we're looking at how racism and
the corona virus have affected mental
health in the black community only one
in three black Americans who need mental
health care receive it psychiatrist dr.
Jess Clemmons uses her ask dr. just
social media accounts she's great to
break down barriers and provide more
access to help she joins us only on CBS
this morning from New Orleans
dr. Jess it's so good to see you you are
the perfect person for this conversation
today because between kovat and
heightened racial tensions i think about
what black americans are living through
these days
listen one of those would be enough to
put you in the fetal position but you've
got the one-two punch
talk about why this is having such a big
effect on mental health in the black
community it seems obvious but maybe not
so much for some people absolutely so
thank you for having me today you know I
think what you're pointing out is
something that black Americans know
intuitively right we know that we're
always hit the hardest and we had the
worst outcomes right but but there are a
lot of studies that actually have looked
at how racism specifically affects a
mental health of those within the black
community right now thinking about you
know George Floyd and police killings
there was a study in 2018 that looked at
what's the impact in terms of mental
health for black Americans who are
living and observing unarmed black
people being killed and what we find is
that for the larger black population
that equates to about 55 million poor
mental health days which affects the
economy and obviously affects the
quality of life and what we do know
about Colvin and natural disasters is
that it tends to lead to an increase in
the number of new cases of mental
illness and so of course when black
people get exposed to things like this
we are expected to get hit the hardest
right so we're expecting to not only
present with symptoms but also have
nowhere to go because of lack of access
and the stigma and barriers associated
with it yeah dr. Jesse you've also
talked about the difference in diagnosis
a black man and a white man can go seek
mental health for the same symptoms but
they get a different diagnosis
what do you mean yes yes so there have
been again a lot of research that have
shown if let's say a black man goes in
to see a psychiatrist with psychotic
symptoms and a white man goes in to see
a psychiatrist with the same psychotic
symptoms the black man is more likely to
be diagnosed with schizophrenia which in
society has you know a larger negative
consequence associated with that and the
white man is more likely to be diagnosed
with bipolar disorder which is an
illness that is thought to sort of have
to be episodic to have periods where the
person is experiencing psychotic
symptoms but otherwise with treatment to
sort of go back to normal and so again
that's very different in terms of how
society views them but also I could say
I thought that African American or black
patient is more likely to not get
treatment and to be incarcerated
actually because of those symptoms yeah
and there's certainly still as a stigma
in the black community about seeking
mental health people say go to church
talk to a friend talk to your family or
better you still keep it in the family
don't take it outside the family do you
think that's changing are you noticing
more black Americans seeking help and
how do we reduce the stigma absolutely I
think you know because of my sort of
unique work using social media to engage
communities black community around
mental illness I certainly have received
a lot of direct messages from people who
have started to engage in therapy or
looking for a therapist so I think there
has been a lot of work in terms of
reducing stigma we have a lot of
celebrities that are very open about how
much therapy has helped them so I do
think that we're going to see a rise in
that but you know there still is a lack
of black psychiatrist they're still you
know are far few black psychologists so
my hope is that this will also encourage
people to pursue this line of work
because we do know that black patients
are more likely to get treated by black
providers and that black providers are
more likely to work in communities that
are underserved in the black communities
especially very good point dr. Clemmens
so how do you stay strong and saying
when you feel so broken inside so I
think you know that that's the
million-dollar
you know I might have been a lot of what
I encourage people to do including my
own patients it's to to find things that
bring them hope to find the things in
their life that that makes them feel
feel good and really to lean into that I
think you know with with working from
home and social distancing my hope is
that people have really leaned into the
love that they can't receive from their
families you know really engaging in
things like breathwork
yoga meditation those can all be things
that a person can do to sort of help
sustain them and as we continue you know
this fight for racial justice and also
to get out of this pandemic to get out
of this pandemic and be with people
listen I was with friends over the
weekend in in in Long Island something I
hadn't done in a very long time and just
being in the studio surrounded by people
you must feel this to Anthony could make
such a difference make such a difference
in how I feel lighter already dr. Jeff
Clemons thank you so much for taking the
time I really really appreciate it if
you or someone you know is seeking
mental health resources you can call the
National Alliance on Mental Illness help
the mental illness helpline is which
he's trying to say at one eight hundred
nine five of sixty two sixty four or in
a crisis text Nami to 741 741 Anthony no